all right this next story contains
everything I hate about modern life
call-out culture company cowardice
people eating on subways
so writer Natasha tines I call her Fink
tweeted a photo of a DC subway employee
eating on a train and then reported her
to her metro bosses saying quote I
thought we were not allowed to eat on
the train this is unacceptable
what a narc transit officials thanked
her but of course social media backlash
ensued and I get it
even though eating on a train is banned
no one likes a tattletale but then the
writers published her a book company
halted printing of the lady's book
citing her thinking on a black worker
now did you see the new variable yep if
things weren't already a barrel of
nonsense the outrage addicted media had
to add race to this mix so California
cold blood books who stopped the
printing say they hope Natasha learns
that black women feel the effects of
systemic racism the most so there it is
everything that makes the present day a
drag all wrapped up into one story
annoying busybodies who use Twitter to
exercise power government employees
breaking rules we gotta follow and of
course knee-jerk instantaneous calls of
racism the only thing that could make
this story more annoying and more
depressing and more stupid is if somehow
the producers here worked maroon 5 into
it
[Music]
well done well done all right Dana I
don't think the story needed a racial
component but why not throw it in right
eye so it's like if I'm just trying to
think I ride the subway a lot you did
you see a lot of things on the subway
but I'm not the boss of those people
right exactly it's not my place to say
you're not supposed to bring your bike
on the subway I hate narcs because maybe
I guys really got to get to his next job
or like what if you have the dog on the
subway then what if you're eating in the
subway because you're working Justine
I've eaten a bagel on the subway
yeah well that's gross but no she might
be actually might have two jobs her kid
might be sick you don't know what's
going on in her life Jessi I argue
though that the writer wasn't racist
because she didn't notice the workers
race or else she wouldn't have done it
because she knew that she would have
gotten in trouble here's why I like this
story you can see what hand beats
another hand politics poker that's funny
so you have right here a black female
Republican union employee okay she her
hand beats a female Muslim immigrant
author
oh she was Muslim yes oh I didn't know I
researched it thank you yeah she's a so
but that's not what this is about this
is snitches get stitches and I have
rules for snitching doodly three times
it's acceptable one snitching on a
sibling yes two snitching on the deep
state that's called whistleblowing and
three if you're paid to snitch like if
you're videotaping a truck idling in
Manhattan but here's here's the real
story was not shucking corn she like had
like a contained package in a sandwich
it was neat and tidy there's no reason
to do anything about it
the the bigger story is the publishing
company they could have capitalized on
this thing this woman has created an
amazing controversy with race and class
and social media and they fire her
instead of I don't know giving her a
three-book deal that they could have her
on NPR the view they could arrange a
suit so it
so backward that makes no sense just to
take identity positive takes a step
further Jesus who would have gotten a
three-book deal if they had done that
who an older white male all right course
you would wanna be cuz evil white males
yeah that's do many villains in this
story but no I tell you what I don't
like people eating on the subway I think
it's wrong I think it's against the
rules
when I saw Dana eating that big picture
to our bosses a nice yeah do I get this
the black got a corner office out of it
here's the over response we know from
the five this program that in fact the
people who are on Twitter is a very
small group right not representative of
most American most people are having
yeah these are people who I think are
bored and looking for something to get
upset about and they did in this case I
think the woman was out of control in
terms of you know trying to get the
woman fired gas problem okay but do I
like eating our subways no and do I like
employees breaking rules at the job no
but to me the real the reality here is
Twitter out of control and we just deal
with this now is part of our lives
unfortunately you know everybody is
tweeting what social mean oh but the
thing is they say it this is another
case where Twitter cost somebody job and
Twitter is free you're not getting paid
to do Twitter but you can lose your
money right well it's always gonna say
it's not just Twitter out of control
it's also these companies allowing
themselves to be held hostage by Twitter
and people on Twitter right like the
idea that somehow racism had anything to
do with this is utterly insane the
writer as Jesse pointed out calls
herself a minority writer and I also
think right now with throwing around
charges of racism so cavalierly you
actually devalue the term and the
accusation right so like if everyone's
erases if you call some a racist that
loses its potency so I think all of this
is just dumb but I will say I used to
live in DC and rode the you know DC
metro and you don't want people eating
on it because that's how you get rats
and it gets gross and then it's just
stinky you know what it's looking like
the New York subway it's about I think
we're sure though on empathy she had no
empathy for that woman is a work she
didn't give it much thought yeah I think
you like taking a picture you're bored
you're like tweeting and thing and then
I hate I I have
say I hate the writers bait that bit
she's like somebody nobody wants to eat
on the subway unless they have to write
so obviously she had to eat because she
had to get somewhere and this lady I
think the lady approached her and said
like you can't do that she said mind
your own business which is love it maybe
she needs to write more and spend time
doing other things yes well I think she
will have free time right now publishing
it's the next big thing what's her name
Natasha